so what we got to do is before you go we
do a game
it's not a game okay no it's it's called
unhelpful advice
and people email us problems oh good and
we answer them
you know what's funny is that you were
right
what do you mean i don't like you
anymore
it's gonna take two minutes this is way
too late
here's a quick question unhelpful advice
with bobby kalila and david spade
hi guys i'm an eight-year-old in a group
of alpha personalities
we all try to dominate to be the most
dominant guy in our group
if you were in this situation how did
you handle it or if not how do you
handle it without being an [ __ ] about
it
thanks for your help noah how old is he
18.
he's a part of an elf the pissing
contest in that age
like i don't think he wants to be a part
of it anymore oh he's like he's just
basically a
rose you guys are in a comic group so
like how do you yeah but i'm not an
alpha male
but why why what you think i mean wait
wait you think i'm a [ __ ] alpha male
when you're in certain groups
you're there no someone who has to try
to be an alpha male is already never
going to be an alpha
hmm an alpha is quiet now i mean alpha
male in front of you in cells
all right when i'm a but a bunch of
[ __ ] weak in cells yeah i dominate
what's an insult
angry virgin they're angry male guys
they hate women
that are celibate without without uh
involuntary uh syllabus yeah okay right
so um no you're not you're a [ __ ]
machine but um
squish it around swish it around i'm not
a a per i'm not a t
no but you get like beautiful girls no
i'm saying i'm not like a uh
i've got some guy friends that are very
type a like
take over any situation have to be
number one drives me nuts
i always let them do their thing
yeah i know you're probably like that
too yes
because it's their drag because guys
like us have to use a different angle
and i use cute right quirky you know
what i mean
and a nice guy kind of an angle mm-hmm
yeah right i do funny things like go
you know i mean at dinner and the girl
goes oh my god why'd you do that
i'll go boop again like that right and
they love it right i'm not like you know
some of the guys we know like
hey look at my [ __ ] my bicep i got a
new tacoma
yeah yeah so i want to tell this guy
right here
right i actually do stop okay so what
are you gonna tell them
what i'm gonna say is is that um it's
you know what i like
i like guys that look like they're alpha
male but they're tender inside
you know do like much like like a
you know jason neck
anthony jeselnik with his leather
jackets
and his brooding you know james deeney
you forgot to say anthony jason like
white guy yeah right yeah
and um and then when you meet him he
just has a smile
and a little you know not not
he could be intimidating though he can
be but jezelnik has a thing where he has
um crows
okay yeah you know because and
white dudes get crinkles in their eyes
because they smile a lot
oh that would make sense i always
thought it was a sun no no no no no they
smile a lot and when they smile their
eyes crinkle right
and so justin like is intimidating at
first and seems like an outfit do you
think that white guys generally smile
more
well it cracks when they smile that's
exciting you smile but
it doesn't do anything yeah why is that
because your skin is great
thank you you know do you have any
advice to the physician
well i like that he's at least doesn't
want to be in that group of like
[ __ ] guys like that it is hard though
because everyone's so
when i was 18 i was following do
whatever was cool i was such a little
plebe
lemming i would do anything everyone's
going there is that cool i think that's
cool
everyone's wearing that shirt i'll wear
that i was
yeah took a while to try to break out
into your own thing
i don't have any advice guys
i mean i don't know it's hard i like
he's aware of it at least he's thinking
about it like
i guess sort of fade out because it's
hard everyone's so tough you go on
barstools for someone just chugging me
it's like you get older you go it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous
i guess it's cool i don't know um you're
ending the plug david do you have
another question
no do you have another there's a there's
a quick question yeah go uh someone
knew uh david was coming out so i asked
how did you guys meet do you remember
the first interaction at least
did you say it okay i just said it what
did we say
you said that i eventually met him but
you didn't say exactly when you met i i
think that um
the first time we kind of had a
conversation with the love after that